all right once you have the center core
so that for wedge pieces are in place
with the interlocking clamps what you're
going to do then is to grab a center
piece the middle Center piece the one
that looks like this it has a Ledge at
one corner and on the other corner there
is no ledge the corner without the ledge
is going to face the inward position of
the cube like that towards the screw
you're going to put the remaining three
on you're probably going to have to hold
it upside down so that the pieces don't
fall off
all right so once you have all four
middle centerpieces you could then rest
the cube the cube core on the table flat
you're then going to take two of the
edge Center pieces the ones that have
the little hooks on them and you should
have two of them with one hook facing
one way and another hook facing the
other way so these basically hook on
like that around the sphere support okay
so what you're going to do is you're
going to put the remaining six pieces on
make sure the hooks are facing the right
way if it doesn't go on its it should go
on very easily if it doesn't go in then
you have to probably switch it be very
gentle because the pieces do come off
it's not really a big deal but it's not
very stable right now
okay so just do that for the remaining
six there's only two pieces remaining
now actually one of them came off
okay so now we have all of those pieces
in place now what you want to do is you
want to put the corner center pieces on
so that basically you're just basically
going to hold it so there's the corner
you want to basically just position it
so that the point of this corner is
facing inward that's basically just rest
like that here's the edge pieces and hit
the corner piece is going to rest like
that on top of it
be very careful with the structure it's
very fragile right now and as you see an
edge piece already popped off again so
just slide that back on and we're going
to put the final corner piece on all
right so now we have the entire Center
complete all right so once you have all
16 center pieces correctly on the first
layer we are then going to put on the
edge pieces and the real corner piece is
not the center corner pieces these are
the real corner pieces okay so you
basically want to grab all the edge
pieces that have black and also all the
corner pieces that have black you're
then going to arrange the edge pieces in
the color pairing scheme that I have
here you're going to have red blue
orange and green in a clockwise
direction you could do the same for the
corner pieces so this is the green red
corner piece the orange green black
corner piece and so forth so then what
you want to do all of the edge pieces
should basically be interlocked so
you're going to take two at a time and
hold them like that and they basically
just fit snugly
like that then you can put the other two
on so it should be seated like that okay
so now you could put on the remaining
twelve edge pieces so then we're going
to put on the orange
and then we could put on the green
and then we get put on the red
okay so now we have all the edge pieces
in place then all you have to do if you
have the corner pieces correctly lined
up in the same color scheme that we had
all we have to do is basically just hold
the black facing downwards and then
we're just going to put the corner piece
in like that it just slides right in so
do that for all four corners as well
make sure that black is facing the
bottom I did not face it but towards the
bottom that time
okay so black facing the bottom slide it
in and black facing the bottom again so
now you have the entire bottom layer
complete alright since I have now showed
you how to complete one layer of the V
cube six you should now have an
understanding of how the pieces do
interlock so what we have to put in next
are going to be the center pieces so I
have put in a edge center piece corner
center piece two of them each so two
corner center pieces two edge Center
pieces so let's do that all the way
around and then you're going to start
with the edge pieces so here I have the
red blue edge piece and that fits in
there like that
the orange blue piece fits in like that
and the green orange piece fits in like
that the red green piece fits in there
like that
alright so you should basically know how
to complete the rest of the cube from
there but I'm going to show you a brief
video at each layer just so you can see
how it should look alright for the third
layer out what you want to do is you
want to get these middle Center pieces
one goes like that and the other one
goes like that then you're going to get
these edge centerpieces what you want to
do the hook should be facing upwards
like that and the color should be out
towards you when you're holding it like
that you should see it's slanted towards
one side if it's slanted to the left
then it goes on the right side here now
the other one you hold it so that the
hook is up and the colors out it's
slanted towards the right so it goes
here on the left side you're then going
to get the middle edge pieces here's the
orange blue so it goes here another
middle edge piece the red blue is going
to go here so that basically completes
the third layer and your cube should
look something like that all right so
after you do the third layer we're going
to have to put in these wedge pieces now
with the interlocking clamps to make
another circular or spherical support in
order to do that you need to take a
wedge piece and you're going to put it
just like that you're then going to take
a set of the interlocking clamp's you're
going to take the big one first and you
want to be sure that you hold the entire
cube put your palm on the back here and
take your pointer finger hold that
corner and take your thumb to hold this
corner you want to have a really tight
grit otherwise the entire cube can come
apart all right so then you're going to
face this little ledge outwards towards
the outwards of the edge of the wedge
that you're then going to rest it on the
side of the wedge like that what you
then want to do is to take the smaller
one and you're going to hold it so that
it is like that with the the little
ledge piece also facing outwards and
you're going to have this top structure
this longer part facing towards you
you're then going to basically slide it
and push it down so that it locks just
like we did for the first four but you
just want to be sure that you have a
really strong grip if you see this piece
is popping out just put them back in
then you're going to take this one and
you're going to face it outwards as well
and then you're going to take the
smaller one make sure that it's facing
outwards and you're going to basically
just slide it and have to put a little
bit of elbow grease into that and then
after that you should basically have
three completed layers and this
spherical support should be surrounding
that